so what other values do you look for in
a man I mean there is a such thing as
being too honest Larissa
okay there is hey my 90 day fans fam
it's Melissa here and just a few I'm
going to update you on all the
highlights from the latest episode of
happily ever after but first you know we
have to get into our biggest must-see
moment which goes to Larissa who went on
a blind date and told all of her
business that's yes I sweets that's miss
you look wonderful
thank you let's take a look at some of
the most cringe-worthy moments from
their day
are you into philanthropy no yes I have
the kids in Brazil why aren't they here
with you because they when I came here I
don't you my ex-husband
Cote a lot you know they called Cote
Colton Kochi
Cody Cody Colt matt Colt guess I got
arrested long time but three times three
times they can explain oh my gosh I was
arguing with my ex-husband
and he just took took at the phone and
call the cops and say but if you say a
lot of you so are you killing a knife
right now I think this is your car okay
awkward everybody hates that moment on a
date right
that's the worst look my heart goes out
to Larissa I'm all for being honest but
I'm all about delivery too it's how you
say it you know
and Larissa missed the mark on that one
speaking of honesty though when I first
saw Matt I was thinking who's this guy
you know but by the end of the day I was
thinking while Larissa you missed out on
a good one
but hey everybody it's not for everybody
answer cut Larissa some slacks single
life and dating is not always easy
actually when I spoke to Larissa earlier
this month she revealed to me what she
misses the most about marry life the
things that are nice about to be married
specifically coltie was when we were
good we were amazing like he play video
games I stayed home watching TV I really
need the road team that we had oh well
next step we have Paul and Carini who
got off to a really rough start when
they landed in America you're breaking
the law
right oh did you just shut your mouth
please love you always make an issue out
of everything because you're breaking a
lot so don't worry about it it's none of
your business right now pull over pull
over pull over pull over
shut up really okay that's all I'm going
to say well finally we have Scylla who
gave Angela and Michael a hard no when
it comes to being a witness at their
nigerian wedding I had to work I have to
take care of the kids I'd take care of
Grandma
I'm sorry mama would be getting married
without me and I know that would hurt
her but I don't that instruction will
make mama happy because they don't have
nothing in common
even though opposites attract their
track but they don't last okay well next
week on happily ever after and Ray and
Elizabeth lived in Moldova for their
wedding it's actually amazing to come
back to my country I feel excited I feel
happy feel like home and Larissa seeks
revenge by reaching out to coax gal aka
Jess I know that took a little bit crazy
but this is not easy I have some things
to tell by the cold all right my 90-day
fans fam make sure you stick with its
heat to stay updated on all the latest
news from our guilty pleasure see you
next time
[Music]